this is what an oil spill last month was
done to this once pristine coastline
along Brazil's north eastern region 1500
kilometers of thick sticky mess that's
damaging the environment at least 42
coastal cities have been affected
president Giles scenario says an
investigation to find out the cause is
still under way by the state-run oil
company Petrobras Bard's he stopped
short of naming a country he believes is
responsible for the spill instead
indicating it could be the result of a
shipwreck or criminal activity the
coastal states affected are particularly
concerned about the timing it's the
season for baby turtle hatchlings and
tourism there could be a severe economic
impact brazilian summer is just around
the corner it starts basically end of
November early December so local
authorities will be hoping that things
are cleared up by there we have seen the
state of soceity
cooling you know declaring this an
emergency this couldn't have come at a
worse time for the president he's been
under international pressure for his
handling of the fires in the Amazon last
month paulson ARA wants to develop the
Amazon through mining and farming in his
recent speech at the UN he accused
environmentalists of wanting to keep the
Amazon tribes like cavemen there have
been protests in cities like Rio de
Janeiro against his policies on climate
change the Brazilian environmental
agency says it has cleaned up more than
a hundred tons of oil washed up or more
than a hundred beaches in the Northeast
and as Brazil investigates who or what
caused the spill it's not clear what the
extent of the damage will be sorrow
pirate al Jazeera